december twenty fourth morning negative
10 Celsius white snow pulled up again
with no feeling in my feet yesterday we
came across some French soldiers at
thick felt foods a kind of a rubber
outside thought to myself I wouldn't
mind a pair of them moon light snow the
trench was that horrible sight the dead
were stretched out on one side one on
top of each other six feet high started
this war with unfounded promises being
taught playing helped in generals war
would be over by Christmas but one now
this was even still stuck in his half
frozen covered in snow trench Christmas
Eve clear beautiful moonlit night frost
on the ground white almost everywhere
but my candle at Christmas tree on top
of the trench as did many others and the
beautiful old songs resounded throughout
the trenches
[Music]
suddenly we hear the English he sang
silent night we're still not I shall
never forget it he sang invoices at
first wavering and firmer swelling into
a mighty Christmas girl together with
then overwhelmed with joy I call out to
the other trench no shoot tonight no
shoot tonight sink tonight sing tonight
so we sang followed with bullets which
both sides near singing everything from
Good King went to slow to all along side
which we all knew everyone joined in it
was absolutely astounding they spend the
remainder of the Christmas Eve watching
the lights flicker and fade on the
Christmas trees
December 25th morning negative nine
Celsius clear sky hook up to the most
peculiar situation one of our soldiers
displayed a board over their trench on
which was written happy Christmas in
English and from the English trenches we
here good morning fritz you reply good
morning silence ensues but after a while
I decide to yell we will come halfway
and you come the other half okay stunt I
grab my cheese ration and get on top of
the trench an English soldier does the
same meet halfway I give him the cheese
and he gives me some [ __ ] suddenly I
turn around and the Germans are standing
on top of their trenches in the English
also with caps waving in the air all
cheering they know proceeding to meet
halfway exchanging gifts and talking to
one another in English and broken
English I shall never forget it it was
one of the highlights of my life
yesterday went by I thought to myself
when the history of the war is written
one of the episodes which chroniclers
will see the phone as one of its most
surprising features will undoubtedly be
the manner in which the phone celebrated
Christmas how they fraternized in each
other's trenches played football Road
races held sing songs and scrupulously
adhere to their unofficial truce it will
certainly go down as one of the greatest
surprises of a surprising one is the
Christmas Day was halting to an end we
all went back to our trenches
unwillingly wishing in our minds from
Flanders kneel and say Godspeed the time
when every day shall be as Christmas Day
december 26 morning negative 12 soldiers
cloudy sky fighting resumed
[Music]
you
[Music]